la ministre monsieur courses et aller au
fond de son lit malade et je vais donc
vous lire sa question qui porte sur le
plan pauvreté faute faire mieux avec
moins c'est un principe qui est devenu
année après année au fil des baisses
inédite des dotations de l'état depuis
la précédente législature
plus qu'une ligne de conduite un credo
et même une condition de survie pour de
nombreuses collectivités et ce malgré
leurs efforts tous aussi inédit pour
certaines d'entre elles de réduction de
dépenses de fonctionnement par respect
de la parole donnée aux électeurs autant
que des deniers publics
fruit du travail de nos compatriotes
mais depuis peu il s'agit de faire mieux
avec plus n'ont pas plus de moyens mais
plus de compétences et plus de dépenses
supplémentaires non compensés par l'état
et le plan pauvreté du gouvernement en
est un parfait exemple pour les conseils
départementaux
car si le président de la république a
annoncé une compensation de 8 milliards
et demi
cela est toujours au de sa de ce que
l'état doit chaque année au département
pour composer les dépenses qu'ils
effectuent pour lui et qu'il ne leur
sont pas remboursés deux exemples
concrets
premier exemple blanc pauvreté renforce
d'accompagnement vers l'emploi en clair
le rsa or avant même cette annonce
l'état ne rembourse que 47 % du coût du
rsa au département et vous leur demandez
de dépenser toujours plus sur leur
budget propre
ce n'est pas raisonnable deuxième
exemple le plan pauvreté est en l'aide
sociale à l'enfance jusqu'à 21 ans
si cela est au coeur de métier du
département la politique migratoire qui
est menée depuis 2012 quant à elle ne
l'est pas et les choix gouvernementaux
en la matière font littéralement
exploser la demande d'accueil des
mineurs étrangers isolés ou mineurs non
accompagnés en politiquement correct
donc avant même cette annonce les
centres d'accueil sont déjà saturées et
vous demandez où département d'aller
encore au delà
là encore ce n'est pas raisonnable
madame la ministre selon un principe
général du droit
personne ne peut se prévaloir de sa
propre turpitude et c'est pourtant bien
ce que fait l'état en se défaussant sur
les conseils départementaux mais plus
généralement sur les collectivités
territoriales
on leur demandant toujours plus
d'efforts budgétaires qui ne s'applique
pas à lui même la parole est à madame
christelle du boss secrétaire d'état
auprès de la ministre des solidarités de
la santé madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice vous m'interrogez sur la mise
en oeuvre du plan de lutte contre la
pauvreté au niveau des collectivités
territoriales vous avez raison la
stratégie doit être mise en oeuvre au
plus près des territoires
l'état a pour mission d'organiser un
pilotage par tous les acteurs
les associations comme les collectivités
à l'échelon régional
les animateurs seront désignés parmi eux
pour faire avancer le travail collectif
sur les différentes thématiques de la
stratégie en ce qui concerne les mesures
relevant de la compétence de
départements chef de file en matière
dette sociale
la stratégie prévoit une
contractualisation ambitieuse avec les
conseils départementaux les travaux de
contractualisation ont déjà été engagées
avec les territoires démonstrateur de la
stratégie et elle sera déployée ensuite
avec l'ensemble des départements avant
la fin du premier semestre 2010 9
la contractualisation s'appuie sur 135
millions d'euros de crédits dans 50
millions de fonds d'appui aux politiques
d'insertion en 2019 et atteindra au
moins 210 millions d'ici 2022
elle porte sur un socle de thématiques
et d'action dans les domaines de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance de l'insertion des
droits fondamentaux des enfants et du
travail social et sur un socle laissé à
l'initiative des départements ils
pourront proposer des actions en lien
avec les ambitions de l'orse de la
stratégie par exemple en matière de
prévention spécialisée ou de pmi auquel
l'état apportera son soutien financier
notre stratégie émane d'une large
concertation de terrain et sa mise en
oeuvre requiert une gouvernance nouvelle
piloter et porté par l'ensemble des
acteurs à partie des territoires
car c'est bien sur les terrains que le
cubain le combat doit être mené
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
catherine procaccia pour 12 secondes
trônerait pouces merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre vous
entendez vous devez entendre dans cette
semaine du congrès des maires le cri d
alarme les départements et des
collectivités nous avons de plus en plus
de personnes à prendre en charge et
la concertation la contractualisation ne
permet pas de faire face à cet afflux de
personnes